got a little bit of a game for you guys
today we're gonna play a movie version
of would you rather so choosing between
the two options and telling me why you
would pick one or the other so first
would you rather work with a director
who gives you too many notes or not
enough hmm not enough I would say not
enough I love being able to come in and
give it a stab you know just me saying
hey here's here's what I want to do and
then I'll ask ya what do you think about
that Robert Zemeckis is such a
collaborative director yeah you know
he's iconic but at the same time he
listens you know he doesn't you don't
get the sense that you're working with
such a genius like that because he's so
open to just hearing what you think or
what are you thinking you know obviously
given notes but never getting in the way
of what the artist wants to do having
done performance capture now would you
rather do that again or have a role
where you have to wear a ton of
special-effects makeup do that again
that was so fun yeah it was super fun
you knew what what you were gonna be
doing and and we got a chance to really
use our imaginations in that world you
know you had to really see the world
that Mark had had created you had to see
that and it felt so like little kids
playing and getting ready in the morning
is a lot faster than would you rather
actually this is probably more
specifically for you Diane would you
rather run throughout an entire scene or
do an entire scene of wire work that
b-roll is something special yeah it is
would you rather have - all right I'll
go with the running thing actually would
you rather have to run throughout an
entire scene or eat throughout an entire
scene run yeah nothing worse than eat
the entire scene imagine 25 takes I did
that once was Easter's and his scene Oh
everybody was throwing up everywhere
I'm always I'm always down for a good
yeah once or twice there maybe five
times right yeah that might be two you
gotta pace yourself the little bit yeah
yeah another thing I feel like a lot of
people don't think about would you
rather have to wake up in a scene or
fall asleep in a scene fall asleep I'd
go with wake up
I think falling asleep for me I never
seem to get enough sleep come on
actually speaking of the oysters
question now would you rather have to
fake vomit in the scene or fake sneeze
in a scene fake sneeze fake vomit is
gross to do no matter what but the
sneeze is challenge to do realistically
a raise down like nobody else so
whatever you have to put in your mouth
to make it look like vomit and hold yeah
it's not it's not great we're thinking
about before you and one of the other
yeah yeah yeah
switching gears a little to wrap this up
this story is very specific to mark's
journey but this idea of healing through
art is such a universal concept so is
there anything you to turn to a hobby
and art anything at all that kind of
gets you to center yourself a little
when you need it music for me yeah yeah
for sure acting for me I mean I think
that's why we choose to do what we're
doing you know in acting just
storytelling and in general is very
helpful allowing yourself to feel those
things is what what keeps you going I
think you know because I think many
people in the real world we get taught
to pretend everything's okay you know
and to not let it touch you and when you
act at least for me it's it's the
opposite and I mean yourself to feel the
pain yeah it's okay to cry it's okay to
be so ecstatically happy you know and
that's what advances you in life that's
very true
you